[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
senate
released a new report this morning
identifying widespread security and
intelligence failures that led to the
january 6th assault on the capitol
the attack by trump supporters is linked
to five deaths
the staggering analysis details critical
breakdowns
involving several federal agencies and
includes multiple recommendations to
address the failures
and protect the capital from possible
future attacks
chris vancleve spoke exclusively with
the four key senators
who spearheaded the bipartisan report
he's on capitol hill chris good morning
good morning anthony this is really the
first big look at what went wrong on
january 6th we sat down with the
senators leading it republicans roy
blunt and rob
portman democrats amy klobuchar and gary
peters what their investigation
found was a litany of problems and
missed opportunities
their recommendations aim to prevent
something like january 6th
from ever happening again what was the
most surprising breakdown or failure
that you
learned about through this investigation
the intelligence failure
how long it took the defense department
to respond
the capitol hill police were not
prepared in any sense
sadly it was the front line officers who
were left to defend us to defend our
staff and to defend democracy
in a rare bipartisan joint interview the
democrats and republicans leading a
senate investigation
sat down for a candid conversation about
what went wrong allowing a mob to storm
the u.s capitol on january
6. their report out this morning found
warning signs were missed by federal law
enforcement
and capitol police part of the reason it
was overlooked is people were saying
well this just can't happen
and these groups of folks they can't do
that well now we know they can
we know that what happens on the
internet can be translated into physical
action
on the capitol grounds or in towns
across this country
we've got to treat domestic terrorism
with the seriousness that it deserves
these police officers were put as i said
in an impossible position right they
didn't have adequate training they
didn't have adequate equipment they
didn't have adequate barriers
they didn't have adequate communication
they didn't have the intelligence to
know what was coming
and yet they valiantly supported the
effort to protect the capital protecting
the vice president protecting all the
members of congress
protecting democracy the report says
around 75 percent of the capitol police
officers working on the 6th did not have
protective equipment like helmets and
shields
one unit wasn't able to access their
gear because it was locked in a bus
some riot shields had been improperly
stored and shattered when used
when the acting chief of staff of the
army was
asked about how come this didn't come
together right away
and he said you know there's these
national guards are incredible
but you just can't pick this moment to
have it be like a pickup game
that they're all going to just be able
to suddenly combine with no contingency
plan in place
he said this was a super bowl of attacks
and you need a plan in place of how this
is going to work
i know that the the focus of the report
was on the
the response and not the the wise uh
the things leading up to this attack but
there there are a couple of points in
there
where they reference the crowd that had
gathered for president trump's
speech uh his speech on the mall is
is is given in its entirety as an
appendix
would the attack on the capital have
happened
without that event on the ellipse
no this wouldn't have happened if he
hadn't done all those things
his false claims of this of
this election is what led to this
insurrection
our job was not to go back and talk
about
what happened in terms of the motivation
it was about okay
once it happened you know what did we do
here in the capitol and how could this
have happened
and how can we ensure it never happens
again doesn't somebody need to look at
the how not just the why yes but at the
same time
you've got the justice department
pursuing 450 prosecutions right now i
think you're going to find
a lot of information that you could only
find in one way
and that's to pursue this through the
legal system and
and that will lead you in new places if
it's necessary to go there
doesn't that kind of give a pass though
to the the rhetoric and the conspiracy
theories that that are being spread even
by members of the senate about
uh the election and what happened on
january 6
the justice department is looking purely
at
you know criminal activity on the day of
january 6.
okay so i just want to intercede here
because roy and i don't agree
on this point our country needs this 911
style commission to get to the bottom of
all this while the prosecutions are
going on you can be looking at
uh the causes and everything but our
mission right now
was to protect this capital going
forward the senate rules committee and
the homeland security and governmental
affairs committee jointly made 20
recommendations
including appointing a new capitol
police chief bolstering training
enhancing communication between law
enforcement agencies
improving coordination across federal
state and local governments
and evaluating threats of violence on
social media
most of the changes the senators believe
can be adopted immediately
marking a rare moment of agreement in a
very divided congress
we believe that our duty was not just to
say oh what a mess this was and we
disagree
part of the message here is that we can
figure this out together
senators klobuchar and blunt plan to
pursue legislation that would allow
the capitol police chief to directly ask
the national guard for assistance in an
emergency like the six
that should speed up guard response if
needed the capitol police
tell us in part it welcomes the analysis
and agrees improvements are needed
specific to intelligence analysis
and dissemination but insisted at no
point prior to the sixth
did it receive actionable intelligence
about a large-scale attack
just last night we learned the number
two at the department who was involved
in the planning and response on january
6th
was forced to resign tony no big
surprise there chris thank you very much
video still every time i see it guys
still so chilling so disturbing because
i think
these are americans going after other
americans
yeah and you notice the eye goes to some
new astounding act of violence caught
on camera every time yes it does it's
interesting you see something new every
time i
i kept hearing about capitol hill police
failures in that report but
it's failures of leadership not the
front line officers
well what's clear is that the report
shows is how vulnerable the capitol
police were
primarily because they didn't a they
didn't have the training
and the equipment but also because they
didn't have the the intelligence they
weren't
they were not worn properly no they
weren't but the officers on the front
lines had the heart to put up a fight
they did
yes they did yes yeah bravo to them and
not to forget
one lawmaker who described it it's like
looking at tourists who were coming to
see the capital that day
that's so upsetting all right
thank you